Alle.
Ich ...
Guten Tag, ich grüße Sie.
Mein Name ist Jakub Olgen.
Ich bin Assistenzarzt auf dieser Station tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, ja, Hauptsache mir hilft jemand.
Ja.
Okay, gut.
Dann bräuchte ich zuerst ein paar persönliche Daten von Ihnen.
Beginne mit Ihrem Namen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Friedrich Schneider.
Können Sie lang zusammen ein Buchstabide?
Den Nachnamen.
Vor- und Nachname.
Ja, also Vorname Friedrich, tatsächlich wieder der neue Bundeskanzler.
F-R-I-E-D-R-I-C-H, Friedrich.
Und Schneider-S-C-H-N-E-I-D-E-R.
Okay, Herr Schneider.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Schneider?
74 bin ich noch.
74, okay.
Und wie groß Sie sind, Herr Schneider?
Ich bin 1,76 m.
Dankeschön.
Und aktuell, wie schwer Sie sind?
Ich wiege ich so ungefähr 89,90 kg, 89, ja.
Okay, Dankeschön, Herr Schneider.
Und jetzt, wie kann ich für Sie tun?
Was kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, also ich habe solche Schmerzen in meinem rechten Bein,
im rechten Unterschenkel.
Und ja, das ist schon vor langer Zeit, hat das mal angefangen.
Aber jetzt wird es mit einem Mal immer schlimmer.
Also wissen Sie, ich habe einen Hund,
mit dem ich regelmäßig spazieren gehe.
Und wir sind immer völlig problemlos, unsere Runde gegangen.
Und ja, und jetzt ist es mit einmal so,
dass mir das weh tut.
Wenn ich länger laufe, dann muss ich auch mal zwischendurch stehen bleiben.
Und jetzt ist es mit einmal ganz plötzlich,
ganz schlimm geworden, seit 3 Tagen.
Ich tut es also nicht nur im Unterschenkel,
sondern auch im Oberschenkel weh.
Und also ich kann nur noch ein ganz kleines Stück laufen
und muss sich einfach stehen bleiben.
Ich verstehe Herr Schneider, seit 3 Tagen sind die Schmerzen schlimmer geworden.
Aber ja, richtig schlimm, ja.
Und eben fliegst schnell.
Vorher haben Sie auch die Schmerzen, genau.
Ja, da musste ich auch zwischendurch mal stehen bleiben.
Aber wie gesagt, diese Runde, Runde haben wir eigentlich immer gut hinbekommen.
Dann war das so, dass ich gemerkt habe,
ja, so erstmal musste ich auf der Runde einmal stehen bleiben
und dann habe ich eine Pause machen.
Und war froh, wenn dann irgendwo was, was ich debank war
oder wenn der Hund seinen Geschäft erledigt hat.
Und ja, dann mit einmal war es 2-mal, dass ich stehen bleiben musste.
Und jetzt, wie gesagt, jetzt kann ich nur ein paar Meter
und dann merke ich, oh, ich kann nicht mehr.
Können Sie mir ja gerne sagen,
können Sie wie viel Meter ohne Pause laufen?
Also ich konnte früher, was war es, ich, 1-2 Kilometer völlig problemlos gehen
und jetzt, also puh, vielleicht 100 Meter oder so,
dann muss ich stehen bleiben, da geht gar nichts.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine Runde oder Verletzungen bemerkt, Herr Schneider?
Verletzungen?
Also ich habe mich nicht gestoßen oder irgendwie umgeknickt
oder irgendwie sowas, aber was mir tatsächlich aufgefallen ist,
dass die Haut sich so ein bisschen verändert hat,
dass das so schuppig geworden ist, die Haut, ja.
Was meinen Sie, schuppig beläsen oder?
Nein, aber dass das so die Oberfläche sich so abschuppt.
Wie Schwellung?
Nein, nein, Schuppen, Hautschuppen, ein Fischhandschuppen.
Ach so, okay, verstehe.
Ja.
Und die Hautfarbe ist eine normale Rötung, die außer Hautschuppen,
außer Schuppen, wie sieht Ihre Haut aus?
Mir ist jetzt nicht aufgefallen, dass sie jetzt irgendwie eine besondere Farbe hat.
Nein, das nicht.
Und haben Sie die Colour, haben Sie die Warmwehrmüche oder fieber ich Ihre Wein bemerkt?
Sie meinen, ob mein Wein heiß ist?
Genau.
Heiß ist es eigentlich nicht.
Nein, also es fühlt sich so ein bisschen taub an und kribbelt so ein bisschen.
Kribbelt?
Im rechten Unterchenkel, genau.
Ja.
Jetzt haben Sie die Schmerzen ist erträglich oder unerträglich?
Ja, wenn ich nicht laufe, geht es, ja.
Aber wenn ich jetzt, also ich wieder bis zum Eingang vom Krankenhaus laufen müsste,
würde es wieder weh tun.
Okay, ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie jetzt eine Schmerz mit Benötigen?
Nein, nein, jetzt kann ich das aushalten, jetzt geht es so.
Okay Herr Schneider.
Und haben Sie Fieber oder fühlen Sie sich generell fieber ich?
Nein, das würde ich nicht sagen, Fieber ich fühle ich mich nicht.
Okay, ist Ihnen über?
Nein, nein, nein, mein Wein tut mir weh.
Okay.
Und aber nur die rechte Wein?
Nur das rechte Wein, ja.
Haben Sie Haarausfall bemerkt?
Haarausfall, ja.
Da sagen Sie, was stimmt, ja.
Auf der Seite sind nicht mehr viele Haare auf den Beinen, ja.
Okay.
Und sind Sie in der letzten Seite verreist?
Verreist?
Nein, ich komme eigentlich kaum raus.
Ich bin ja alleine mit meinem Hund, also macht man nicht viel Reise.
Okay.
So Herr Schneider, jetzt ich fasse zusammen.
Sie haben seit langer Schmerzen, rechter Unterdenker,
aber seit drei Tagen sind die Schmerzen schlimmer geworden.
Ganz genau.
Sie können ohne Pause maximal 100 Meter laufen
und Sie müssen Stern bleiben und Pause machen.
Und Trauma oder Stürzen, keine Bechte?
Also ich bin weder hingefallen, noch habe ich mich gestoßen, genau.
Okay.
Und Sie haben bemerkt,
die rechte Unterdenkerhaut, Schuppig.
Dass die Haare tupig ist, das habe ich bemerkt, genau.
Okay.
Und ich habe weiterfragen.
Müssen Sie schon erwähnen?
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben keine Übelkeit?
Nein, nein, nein.
Über Gottes Willen, nein.
Wie gesagt, mein Bein tut mir weh.
Haben Sie verdammt beschwerten, Herr Schneider?
Verdammt beschwerten, nein, eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Und haben Sie bemerkt, ob in der Lesserzeit Sie abgenommen oder zugenommen haben?
Nein, mein Gewicht ist eigentlich immer ziemlich gleich.
Gut.
Und schwitzeln Sie viel?
Eigentlich nicht so besonders, also ich würde sagen normal.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit, Herr Schneider?
Der ist eigentlich schon gut, aber ich muss ein bisschen aufpassen.
Bei mir ist so ein Diabetes bekannt, so ein Altersdiabetes halt.
Und da muss ich halt Tabletten nehmen.
Da darf ich jetzt halt nicht ganz unbeschränkt essen.
Dann muss ich ein bisschen aufpassen.
Okay.
Jetzt können wir sagen, Sie haben keine Appetitlosigkeit.
Nein, ich würde nicht sagen, Sie.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihr Schlafen? Schlafen Sie gut oder?
Ja, ich muss zwar nachts mal auf die Toilette, aber so ein bis zweimal,
aber ich denke mal, das ist in meinem Alter ja auch normal, oder?
Okay.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang, Herr Schneider?
Bitte was?
Beim Stuhlgang.
Stuhlen.
Ja?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Hat ich Ihnen aufgefallen?
Nein, da habe ich keine Probleme.
Okay.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben nicht hingefallen.
Ich bin nicht hingefallen.
Aber trotzdem möchte ich fragen, haben Sie das bewusst sein per Lohren, oder?
Nein.
Ja.
Okay.
Und jetzt möchte ich Ihre Vorgeschichte, Vorerkrankungen ein paar Fragen stellen.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben alte Zucker.
Ich gehe davon aus, Sie nehmen Medikamente, Tabletten oder Spritze?
Nee, Medikamente nehme ich, ne?
Herr Dorn, wie viele Milligramm müssen Sie? 1.000?
Nee, das ist 800, dann nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends.
Okay.
Und außer Zuckerkrankheiten? Leiden Sie noch andere Krankheiten?
Ja, was man halt so im Alter hat, ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck.
Nehmen Sie dagegen eine Medikamente ein?
Ich weiß gar nicht.
Also ich nehme eigentlich 2 Sachen, 3 Sachen.
Ich nehme ein Dismetformin, dann nehme ich Simvastatin, dann nehme ich abends eine Tablette
und dann nehme ich noch Aspirin.
Warum nehmen Sie Aspirin?
Bitte?
Warum? Warum nehmen Sie Aspirin ein?
Ja, das hat mir mein Hausarzt verschrieben, das wäre gut, hat er gesagt.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie der gelmäßige Aspirin ein?
Ja, so Aspirin ein 100-mal morgens, das kriegen ja ganz viele Leute, ja.
Okay.
Sie haben nicht gesagt, Herr Schneider, Simvastatin, wissen Sie, Dossierung?
Simvastatin von Dossierung?
Ich meine, das steht 20 drauf auf der Packung.
20 Milligramm, ja.
Okay.
Und Sie haben gesagt, Herr Schneider, in der Nacht ein, zwei Mal auf die Toilette gehängt.
Leiden Sie Posteratur oder Vorhördrösen Probleme?
Also ich bin da regelmäßig in der Kontrolle, also da ist nichts Schlimmes,
aber so ein bisschen vergrößert ist die Posteratur wohl und dann muss ich halt heute weggehen.
Aber nehmen Sie da gegen, keine Medikamente?
Und Medikamente nehme ich eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Und, wo denn Sie schon mal operiert, Herr Schneider?
Das muss ich überlegen, ja, als Kind bin ich mal operiert worden, da habe ich mal den Blindarm rausbekommen
und die Polypen habe ich mal rausgekriegt, aber alles schon lange her
und sonst bin ich noch nicht operiert worden, ne?
Opendectomy in der Kindheit, Polypen Entfernung auf in der Kindheit.
Ja, ja, als Kind, also war ich noch ganz klein.
Wo befindet sich dieser Polypen?
In der Nase.
Okay, Herr Schneider.
Ich möchte fragen, Herr Schneider, reagieren Sie allergisch auf etwas?
Ich wüsste nicht, dass ich auf irgendwas allergisch bin.
Ne, ich kann alles essen, ich habe kein Heuschnumpfen oder sowas, was ja zu anderen Leute sagen
und Medikamente, na gut, nehme ich nicht so viel, aber ich wüsste nicht, dass ich gegen irgendwas allergisch bin.
Okay, okay, Herr Schneider.
Jetzt möchte ich nun ein paar Fragen über Ihre Lebensgewohnheiten.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Schneider?
Ne, schon lange nicht mehr, ich habe lange geraucht, wissen Sie, ich war Gastwirt, ich habe eine eigene Kneipe gehabt,
da habe ich halt so tagsüber schon mitgeraucht, ja.
Seit wann rauchen Sie nicht?
Ja, ich hauch jetzt schon 20 Jahre nicht mehr, oder 15 Jahre vielleicht.
Okay, wie viele Zigaretten pro Tag haben Sie geraucht?
Nie so richtig exzessiv viel, eigentlich nur so ein halbes Päckchen, ich habe immer nur so aus Gesellschaft mitgeraucht.
Wie lange dauert 20 Jahre?
Nie länger, länger, länger, ich bin ja schon 74, also ich würde dann ja 40 Jahre, habe ich bestimmt geraucht, ja.
Okay, dir kennen Sie Alkohol, Herr Schneider?
Ja, ist so noch gelegen, ich habe früher natürlich ein bisschen mehr getrunken, ja, da habe man in der Kneipe schon mal ein Bier mitgetrunken und am Schnaps oder so,
aber jetzt eigentlich sehr gelegen, ich bin nicht mal mit Freunden treffer oder so, aber das ist nicht so oft und mal eine Flasche Bier am Abend,
aber eigentlich trinke ich nicht viel Alkohol.
Ein Flasche Bier am Abend skellegen mich.
Okay, ich muss auch fragen Herr Schneider, konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Drogen, sehe ich so aus, nein, nein, nein, Drogen konsumieren ich natürlich nicht.
Okay, ich bin glücklich.
Und nun habe ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Familie Herr Schneider.
Du meine Familie, ja, ich bin allein, ich habe keine Familie mehr.
Sind Ihre Eltern noch leben?
Ja, das wäre ganz wunderbar, wenn die noch leben würden. Ich bin 74 Jahre alt.
Also die 100-Jährigen sind ja nicht so reich gesehen.
Nein, meine Eltern sind natürlich schon beide verstorben, die sind auch gar nicht so alt geworden.
Tut mir leid, beim Ehevater.
Ja, der hat den Herzinfarkt, der ist nicht alt geworden, der ist mit 60 Jahren, hat er seinen Herzinfarkt, der hat nichts von seiner Rente gehabt.
Ihr Vater ist an Herzinfarkt im Alter von 60 Jahren gestorben.
Ganz genau, ja.
Ihre Mutter?
Ja, die ist ein bisschen älter geworden, aber ja, der ist eigentlich auch blöd gegangen, die hatte dann zum Schluss und hatte eine Lungenembolie und da dran ist sie gestorben.
Okay, haben Sie geschwistert Herr Schneider?
Nein, ich war alleine.
Okay, so sind Sie 74 Jahre alt, ich denke, Sie sind Trendner.
Ich bin Trendner jetzt, ja, ja klar.
Okay, früher haben... was machen Sie früher?
Was habe ich früher gemacht, wollen Sie wissen?
Ja, ich habe ja gesagt, wir hatten eine Kneipe, ich war Gastwirt.
Ich war Gastwirt, wir hatten eine Kneipe, ein Rest, also eben weniger Essen, sondern mehr, wo man was trinken konnte, wo man sich so getroffen hat und wo es mal so Kleinigkeiten zu essen gab, aber so eine richtige Kneipe nach statt.
Okay, haben Sie als Gastwirt gearbeitet?
Ich habe als Gastwirt gearbeitet, genau.
Okay, sind Sie...
Sie sind abends immer lange.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verwirrt.
Verwirrt?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder, Herr Schneider?
Nein, wir hatten keine Kinder.
Deswegen, ich bin nur noch alleine mit meinem Hund, ja.
Okay.
Ach, ich habe gerade vergessen.
Wie ist Ihr Impfstatus?
Ja, als diese Corona-Sache war, da habe ich mich natürlich impfen lassen, das hat man ja den alten Leuten damals empfohlen, aber sonst wüsste ich jetzt nicht, ja, so eine Grippeimpfung mache ich auch immer mit, da war man ja auch bei alten Leuten und sagt, das ist besser, wenn man sich impfen lässt, ne?
Okay.
So, Herr Schneider, ich habe alle wichtigsten Fragen gestellt. Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich habe Ihnen ja schon so viel erzählt und ich will jetzt eigentlich nur wissen, warum mir mein Bein so wehtun und was man dagegen tun kann, dass es wieder besser wird, ja.
Ja, Sie haben Bluthoffdruck und Sie haben Zuckerkrankheit, deswegen haben Sie zwei mehr chronische Erkrankungen, deswegen möchte ich sagen, könnte Ihre Beinschlagader verschlossen.
Oh, ja, oh, ist das gefährlich?
Eigentlich, Sie können in diesem Moment 100 Meter laufen, das ist nicht so gefährlich, aber wir müssen auf jeden Fall behandeln.
Ja, und das kann man da machen?
Wie bitte?
Das kann man da machen.
Natürlich, zuerst muss ich Sie körperlich untersuchen und dann ein paar Labor- oder Labor-Untersuchungen durchführen, auch ein paar operative, bildgebende Experien durchführen bei Ihnen.
Und dann, wenn meine Diagnose aufrechtätigen, dann die auch eine Verstopfung, eine Verschluss im Schlagader, im Beinabfall, müssen wir die Verstopfung entfernen.
Eine Verstopfung entfernen?
Ja, das kommt spannend, ja. Aber das erklären Sie mir dann noch, wenn das notwendig ist.
Dankeschön. Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch eine Frage?
Darf ich?
Bitte schön.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen, wenn Sie bewegen?
Oh, die sind schon toll, die Schmerzen sind ziemlich düstig, ansonsten würde ich nicht sehen bleiben.
Okay, wenn ich eine Schmerzkader schätzen würde, auch von 1 bis 10.
Ja, also 7 von 10 gibt es da.
Dankeschön.
Noch eine Frage?
Ich denke nicht, alle wichtige Fragen gestärkt.
Ich denke, alles entscheidende ist gefragt worden, ja.
Können wir auch das bitte schön.
Herr Ol, gebrauchen Sie noch eine Minute oder können wir weitermachen?
Weiter machen, wir können weitermachen.
Sehr gut.
Guten Abend Frau Oberestin, habe ich eine Küssezeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen, deswegen möchte ich die Patienten vorstellen.
Es handelt sich um Friedrich Neider, er ist 74 Jahre alt und 1,76 m groß und er wiegt seit 89 kg.
Er stellt sich heute bei uns, wegen 3 Tagen bestehenden Rechtsseitungen unter Schmerzen vor.
Die Schmerzinterstate liegt bei 7 von 10 auf einer Schmerzkala.
Außerdem gab der Patient an Parästhesie.
Der Patient klappt über Haarausfall im betroffenen Bereich.
Die Hautveränderungen sind wie Schuppenbildungen.
Der Patient kann ohne Pause 100 m laufen seit 3 Tagen.
Wie lange konnte er vorher laufen?
Er konnte ohne Pause 2-3 km laufen.
Bis vor 3 Tagen?
Nein, vorher kann er ohne Pause 1-2 km laufen.
Aber seit 3 Tagen muss er nach 100 m stehen bleiben.
Er kann ohne Pause 1-2 km laufen.
Die Frage nach Fieber und Bötung wurde verneint.
In der Vegetaritalkanamnesie fanden sich Nuktyri.
Die Diabetes Melitus ist der Typ 2 und Artilielle Hypertonie bekannt.
Er nimmt 800 mg morgens.
Er nimmt 20 mg abends.
Er nimmt 100 mg morgens.
Sie leidet an Beninprostata Hypertroidae.
Die Operationen sind Appendectomy und Polypectomy bekannt.
Die beiden Opie in der Kindheit durchgeführt.
Bei ihm sind keine Allergien bekannt.
Er fand sich Lungenembolie bei der Mutter und Herzinfarkt beim Vater.
Der Vater ist an Herzinfarkt im Alter von 60 Jahren gestorben.
Die Mutter ist an Lungenembolie gestorben.
Er ist Einzelkind und hat keine Geschwister.
Er hat vor 15 Jahren Halbespekschen geraucht.
Er trinkt gelegentlich Alkohol, ein vielleicht ein Bier.
Er ist jetzt im Moment ein Rentner.
Er ist jetzt im Moment ein Gast.
Er ist jetzt im Moment ein Hund.
Er ist jetzt in einer Arteriellen-Ferschul-Krankheit.
Er kommt in Betracht, Tiefwähnendrungen, Trombe, Embolie oder viele Wähnenentzündungen.
Er kommt in die Autopädie rein.
Er hat auch eine Fraktur oder Luxation.
Er hat auch eine Arteriellen-Ferschul-Krankheit.
Er hat eine Arteriellen-Ferschul-Krankheit.
Er hat ein Tiefwähnendrungen.
Er hat ein Füßnagel oder Fussnagel.
Er hat auch eine Fussnagel oder Fussnagel.
Er hat ein Fussnagel oder Fussnagel.
Er hat eine Bechtemte Socken.
Er hat eine Bechamung.
Er hat eine Blutgerinsel-Lösungstherapie.
Er hatte eine stehbelastende Leidenschaft.
Er hatte eine Leidenschaft.